[Music]
okay there we go
NBC London done for another year and
it's what two months until Copenhagen so
I'm doing I got a two-day workshop on
building hypermedia and asp.net a whole
bunch of stuff around API is and dynamic
piping and services and then doing a
talk on Friday about the legacy code and
you know ways that people should start
thinking of better ways of working with
that way man what you gonna be doing
super-nice so I'll be doing a 2-day
workshop on blockchain programming and
how to deploy smart contracts on to the
ETM network so this actually today's
workshop I'll be giving two talks one on
react native and how to use to react
native to develop cross-platform mobile
apps and the other talk that I'll be
talking about is on blockchain
programming how about you Sam well that
sounds great I'd love to be doing a
blockchain workshop but I'm doing a
two-day workshop of my own learning
about micro services we don't have 20
people in the class talking about all
the new cool technology in this space
how you build these things yourselves
how you make the result robust and
resilient and then Friday we can be
talking about service funding I talk all
about my sort of last two years trying
to understand what services and gonna be
talking about that journey what about
you not so yeah I'm doing I'm not doing
a workshop because I am a lazy man so
I'm doing two talks on the Friday which
both have native in the name but are
completely different things run on cloud
native applications with dotnet core
kubernetes prometheus all that good
stuff and another one on building native
executables
we've got net core RT which lets you
take the C sharp code and you don't make
code and create a binary executable and
for that so that's all I'm doing that
all sounds awesome have you guys been to
Copenhagen before it is a very very fun
city I think it's gonna be a great
setting for NDC it's got some really
cool restaurants a couple of really
interesting bars there's a street food
market paper island I'd to say pepper
Owen but the Danish people will laugh at
my pronunciation war pigs are generals
mac and cheese micro breweries and of
course three days of Awesome
deceased oh I can't wait it's gonna be
good
[Music]